المدير العام لسياسات الدفاعيه في وزاره
الدفاع الفنلنديه مرحبا بك سيد يانكوسيلا
هل كانت فنلندا بالفعل بحاجه للانضمام الى
الناتو وهي التي تتمتع بعلاقات ممتازه مع
روسيا
لاوكرانيا
وطبعا تغيرت بيئه الامن الاوروبيه بشكل
كامل واستنادا الى هذا التغيير وصلنا الى
استنتاج في فنلندا مفرده ان من الافضل لنا
ان ننضم الى حلف النيتو ولكن ما النتيجه
الان بالاعلان عن انضمامكم الى حلف الناتو
تعلن روسيا انها ستعسكر الحدود مع فنلندا
وهو ما لم يكن حاصل سابقا
اننا الان ضدنا جزءا من تحالف يضم واحدا
وثلاثين دوله وهذا يشكل دعما كبيرا للدفاع
في فنلندا وترى فنلندا ان هذا الامر سيلعب
دورا كبيرا ويضيف الكثيره لامننا القومي
لكن المسؤولين روسيا يقولون ان هذا
التهديد الذي تخشاه فنلندا لم يكن موجودا
اصلا وان انضمامها الى الناتو الان
يوجد هذا التهديد الروسي يعني ياتي بنتيجه
عكسيه على فنلندا كيف تردون على ذلك
تاويلنا وتفسيرنا للامور مختلف تماما
الانضمام الى النيتو ليس موجها بشكل مباشر
ضد اي ترفع
هو تحالف او حلف
ركز على الدفاع عن اعضائه وهو لم يكن وجها
ضد اي بلد اخر ولكن ربما ليس هذا ما تفهمه
روسيا لان المسؤولين الروس لن يتحدثون عن
نشر الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه على الحدود
مع فنلندا على الحدود الغربيه لروسيا
انا اترك هذا الامر للسلطات الروسيه انا
لست في موقع يتيح للتعليق على مثل هذه
الامور لكن كيف تعتقد يمكن للسلطات
الفنلنديه ان تتعامل مع هكذا معطى
سنتعامل مع الامر كما فعلنا دائما
فنلندا دائما احتفظت نفسها بقدرات دفاعيه
كبيره الان نحن معنا حلف باسره وكما قلت
انضمامنا لهذا الحلف ليس موجها ضد اي دوله
نحن بلد صغير وسكان لا يتجاوزون خمسه ونصف
مليون نسمه ونحن دائما بحاجه الى تعزيز
امننا شكرا لك ينكوسيلا المدير العام
لسياسات الدفاعيه في وزاره الدفاع
الفنلنديه ضيفنا من هيلسنكي